lovis cazalis et lui aussi notre ans et
spéciale à kiev la capitale bonsoir à
vous clovis vous avez à suivirent tous
les derniers développements de la
journée il fait nuit maintenant dans la
capitale où vous vous trouvez un couvre
feu a été mis en place clovis ans entre
22h et 7h du matin il n'y a plus de
transport dans les rues revanche en
revanche des stations de métro sont
toujours ouvertes pour la population qui
souhaitent s'y mettre à l'abri
et on entend des détonations ici à kiev
au loin pas dans le centre ville bien
évidemment de kiev mais aux alentours la
journée a été rude a été très compliqué
pour les ukrainiens avec ces
bombardements
ces tirs de missiles ces opérations
terrestres une offensive de grande
envergure menée par les russes contre
l'ukraine alors un petit peu de
confusion sur les combats notamment
l'aéroport minutes militaire de ghost au
mail tout d'abord on nous a dit que les
russes l'avaient pris puis on a des
informations comme quoi les ukrainiens
auraient repoussé les assaillants et
auraient repris le contrôle de
l'aéroport de ghost au mal et puis il ya
le site la centrale de tchernobyl qui
est aujourd'hui aux mains des russes
cette centrale de tchernobyl qui se
trouve à environ 130 kilomètres au nord
de kiev alors que l'aéroport dont je
vous parlais et a à peine 30 km alors
beaucoup de confusion une journée de
combats un peu partout en russie et
forcément les ukrainiens ont de plus en
plus peur ils craignent une invasion une
opération qui viserait directement à
kiev on peut imaginer que le président
vladimir poutine voudrait et bien mettre
la pression maximale sur l'ukraine et
sur la capitale et son président
zelensky oui puis clovis on
imaginé ce scénario même si beaucoup se
refusait à se projeter à imaginer que
cette guerre puisse puisse être amorcées
vous avez vu vous même des civils furent
tout au long de la journée quand est il
ce soir
avec un réveil dès l'aube avec des
explosions pour les ukrainiens et
notamment ici à kiev et donc beaucoup
ont pris la route très rapidement ils
ont rassemblé leurs affaires leurs
familles ils ont pris la route ils sont
partis en voiture causant d'énormes
embouteillages à la sortie de la
capitale ukrainienne et il ya eu aussi
des files d'attentes interminables
devant les stations essence je peux vous
dire qu'il y avait beaucoup de monde on
est allé par exemple devant une station
essence il y avait 200 m deux files de
voitures des gens parfois à pied avec
des jerricanes venus faire des
provisions des gens prêts à attendre une
heure pour l'instant il y avait encore
de l'essence dans cette station mais qui
sait demain avec les problèmes
d'approvisionnement et donc beaucoup
d'ukrainiens ont fui certains ont essayé
de partir et ont décidé de revenir vu la
situation est peut-être aujourd'hui ils
sont à l'abri en tout cas le
gouvernement ukrainien leur a dit de
rester chez eux et de descendre dans les
abris si des bombardements avaient lieu
ici dans la capitale ukrainienne le cren
donc qui dit se défendre le président
zelensky qui appellent aux armes et le
ministre des affaires étrangères
ukrainien s'est entretenu tout à l'heure
avec son homologue son homologue
américain les etats unis qui ont promis
de livrer des armes défensives et aussi
d'accroître les sanctions c'est en tout
cas ce que lorsqu'on rapporte ici à kiev
vous citiez l'instant à clovis le
président céline ski qui a réussi à se
muer en chef de guerre il a aussi réussi
à créer ce sentiment d'appartenance à
une nation unie une nation ukrainienne
l'heure est à l'union nationale bien
évidemment ici en ukraine l'ukraine qui
est attaqué par la russie et le
président zelensky qui s'est adressé
plusieurs fois à la nation via des
conférences de presse mais aussi avec
des adresses directement sur les réseaux
sociaux relayés notamment
président céline ski qui leur a demandé
de prendre les armes les ukrainiens qui
veulent prendre les armes peuvent le
faire c'est de l'autodéfense et donc ils
se sont rendus dans les armureries pour
récupérer ce qu'ils peuvent pour réagir
si l'agresseur vient chez eux c'est ce
que demande le président zelensky
l'union nationale et le président
azzedine chih qui déclare que vladimir
poutine cherche tout simplement à
détruire l'ukraine il le compare même un
chef nazi il a rappelé que les nazis
était entré ici en ukraine pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale et pour lui
c'est exactement ce que fait bladier
même vladimir poutine alors que la
russie de son autre que de l'autre côté
dit qu'elle en train de des nazis fier
l'ukraine des propos très fort bien
évidemment du président russe des
accusations lourdes pas du tout accepté
par l'occident notamment et le cren en
appel à une coalition anti poutine une
coalition pour mettre un terme à ce
qu'ils appellent une agression pour
faire pression sur vladimir poutine pour
qu'il arrête ses opérations dès que
possible mais ici à kiev ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que c'est plutôt une
opération russe ici dans la capitale que
les gens craignent et pourquoi pas dans
les prochaines heures comme hier soir
dans la nuit quand les russes ont
attaqué un grand merci à vous clovis
clovis casali en direct depuis kiev et
puis depuis le début tu sais